Je suis vicaire de l'Eglise d’Angleterre
J'ai été prêtre pendant 20 ans
La plupart du temps j'ai lutté et j'ai été aux prises
avec des questions sur la nature de Dieu. Qui est Dieu ?
Je suis conscient du fait qu'à partir du moment ou vous prononcez le mot Dieu,
beaucoup de personnes se ferment instantanément.
La plupart des personnes, appartenant à l'Eglise ou pas,
a encore l'image d'un contrôleur céleste,
un dicteur de règles, un policier dans le ciel qui gère tout,
et qui est la cause de tout.
Il protègera son peuple,
et répondra aux prières des fidèles.
Dans le culte de mon église,
l'adjectif qui revient le plus souvent est "tout-puissant"
Mais j'ai un problème avec ça.
Je suis devenu de plus en plus mal à l'aise,
au fil des années, avec cette perception de Dieu.
Croyons-nous vraiment que Dieu est le genre de patron masculin que nous présentons
dans notre culte et dans nos liturgies depuis toutes ces années?
Bien sûr, il y a eu des courants de pensées
qui ont suggéré différentes façons de voir Dieu.
Explorant le féminin, le coté nourrissant de la divinité.
Suggérant qu'IL ou ELLE s'exprime à travers l'impuissance,
plutôt qu'à travers le pouvoir.
Reconnaissant que Dieu, par définition, est inconnu et inconnaissable.
Trouvant de profondes résonances avec les autres religions et philosophies
et d'autres façons de voir la vie dans le cadre de la quête universelle et globale de sens.
Ces idées sont bien connues des cercles académiques libéraux,
mais le clergé, comme moi, avons été réticents à les diffuser,
de peur de créer des tensions et des divisions dans les collectivités de notre église;
de peur de heurter la foi simple de croyants plus traditionnels.
J'ai choisi de ne pas faire de vagues.
Puis, le 26 décembre dernier, il y a deux mois,
ce tremblement de terre sous-marin à provoqué le tsunami.
2 semaines plus tard, Dimanche matin, le 9 Janvier,
Je me suis retrouvé, debout, devant ma congregation --
intelligents, bien intentionnés, principalement des chrétiens attentionnés --
et j'ai eu besoin, en leur nom, d'exprimer nos sentiments et nos questions.
J'avais mes propres réponses personnelles, mais j'ai également un rôle public,
et quelque chose avait besoin d'être dit.
Voici ce que j'ai dit.
Peu après le tsunami, j'ai lu, dans un journal, un article
écrit par l’Archevêque de Canterbury -- joli titre --
sur la tragédie en Asie du sud.
L'essence de ce qu'il a dit était :
les gens les plus affectés par la dévastation et la perte de la vie
ne veulent pas de théories intellectuelles sur comment Dieu laisse-t-il arriver cela.
Il a écrit : "Si un génie religieux arrivait avec une explication
sur le sens de toutes ces morts,
nous sentirions-nous plus heureux, ou plus sur, ou plus confiant en Dieu?"
Si l'homme sur la photo du journal,
tenant la main de son enfant mort était face a nous maintenant,
Il n'y a aucun mot que nous pourrions lui dire.
Une réponse verbale ne serait pas appropriée.
La seule réponse appropriée serait un silence de compassion
et une sorte d'aide pratique.
Ce n'est pas le moment de l'explication, des prêches, ou de la théologie;
c'est le temps des larmes.
C'est la vérité. Et nous y voilà, mon église à Oxford,
jumelé avec des évènements qui se sont produits loin de chez nous,
mais avec notre foi meurtrie.
Et nous voulons des explications de la part de Dieu.
Nous demandons une explication de la part de Dieu.
Certains en ont conclus que nous pouvons seulement croire en un Dieu qui partage notre douleur
Dans un sens, Dieu doit sentir l'angoisse, le chagrin,
et la douleur physique que nous ressentons.
Dans un sens, le Dieu éternel doit être capable de pénêtrer nos âmes d'êtres humains
et de connaitre notre tourment intérieur.
Et si c'est vrai, ce Dieu doit également bien connaitre la joie et l'exaltation
de l'esprit humain.
Nous voulons un Dieu qui pleure avec ceux qui pleurent,
et se rejouit avec ceux qui se réjouissent.
Il me semble que c'est, en même temps, un profond changement et un réajustement convaincant
de la croyance Chrétienne sur Dieu
Pendant des centaines d'années, l'orthodoxie en vigueur, la vérité acceptée,
était que Dieu le Père, le Créateur, est immuable
et donc, par définition, ne peut pas ressentir la douleur ou la tristesse.
Maintenant, le dieu immuable me parait un peu froid et indifférent.
Et les évènements désastreux du 20ème siècle
ont amené les gens à questionner le Dieu froid et insensible.
Le massacre de millions de gens dans les tranchées et dans les camps de la mort
ont amené les gens à se demander, où est Dieu dans tout cela ?
Qui est Dieu dans tout cela?
Et la réponse à été, " Dieu est avec nous,
ou Dieu ne mérite plus notre dévouement"
Si Dieu est un spectateur, observant mais pas impliqué,
alors Dieu peut bien exister, mais nous ne voulons pas connaitre son existence.
Je sais que beaucoup de juifs et de chrétiens ont maintenant ce sentiment.
Et j'en fais partie.
Nous avons donc un Dieu souffrant.
Un Dieu qui est intimement connecté avec ce monde, et avec toutes les âmes vivantes.
Je suis très proche de cette idée de Dieu.
Mais ce n'est pas assez. J'ai besoin de poser plus de questions.
et j'espère également que certains d'entre vous souhaiteraient poser ces questions.
.
Ces dernière semaines, j'ai été frappé pas le nombre de fois
ou les mots dans nos offices ont semblés légèrement inappropriés, un peu suspects
Nous avons un "service poussette" le mardi matin pour les mères et leurs enfants de maternelle
La semaine dernière nous avons chanté, avec les enfants, une de leur chanson favorite,
"L'homme sage a construit sa maison sur le rocher"
Peut-être certains d'entre vous la connaissent. Les paroles donnent cela :
"L'homme insensé a bâti sa maison sur le sable/
les torrents sont venus/Et la maison sur le sable s'est ecroulée"
Puis la même semaine, à des funérailles,
nous avons chanté l'hymne connu "Nous avons labouré les champs et semé,"
un chant très anglais.
Dans le second couplet les lignes suivantes sont chantées, "Le vent et les vagues lui obéissent"
Vraiment? Je ne crois pas que nous pouvons chanter de nouveau cette chanson à l'eglise,
aprés ce qu'il s'est produit.
Ainsi, la première grande question porte sur le contrôle.
Dieu a-t-il un projet pour chacun de nous? Dieu est-il aux manettes ?
Dieu commande-t-il chaque instant? Le vent et les vagues lui obéissent-ils ?
Parfois,
on entend des chrétiens racontant comment Dieu à organisé les choses pour eux,
faisant en sorte que tout se passe bien.
une difficulté surmontée, une maladie guérie, un problème évité,
une place de parking trouvée à un moment crucial.
Je me souviens quelqu'un me disant ça,
avec ses yeux brillants d'enthouisasme à la vue de cette merveilleuse confirmation de sa foi
et de la bonté de Dieu.
Mais si Dieu peut et veut faire ces choses --
s'interposer pour changer le cours des évènements --
alors il aurait surement pu stopper le tsunami.
A-t-on un Dieu local qui peut faire de petites choses comme des places de parking,
mais pas de grandes choses comme des vagues lancées à 800 km/h?
C'est juste inacceptable pour des chrétiens intelligents,
et nous devons le reconnaître.
Soit Dieu est responsable du tsunami,
soit Dieu n'est pas au contrôle.
Après la tragédie, des histoires de survivants on commencé à émerger.
Vous en avez surement entendu quelques unes.
L'homme qui a surfé la vague.
L'adolescente qui a reconnu le danger
car elle venait juste d'apprende ce qu'était un tsunami à l'ecole.
Puis, il y avait une congregation qui avait quitté leur église habituelle construite sur le rivage
pour assurer son service dans les collines.
Le pasteur a prononcé un très long sermon,
de sorte qu'ils était hors de danger au moment ou la vague à frappée.
Ensuite quelqu'un a dit que Dieu veillait sur eux.
La deuxième question porte donc sur la partialité.
Gagnons-nous la bienveillance de Dieu en l'adorant ou en croyant en lui ?
Dieu exige-t-il fidélité, comme n'importe quel tyran du moyen-âge ?
Un Dieu veillant sur les siens, de cette façon tous les Chrétiens survivent,
pendant que tous les autres périssent?
Un nous et eux cosmique, et un Dieu coupable de la pire forme de favoritisme?
Ce serait effroyable,
et ce serait le moment de présenter ma démission.
Un tel Dieu serait moralement inférieur aux idéaux les plus grands de l'humanité.
Qui est Dieu, donc, si ce n'est pas le grand marionnettiste ou le protecteur tribal?
Peut-être Dieu autorise ou permet que ces choses épouvantables se produisent.
ce qui permet de faire preuve d’héroïsme et de compassion.
Peut-être Dieu nous teste: Il teste notre charité, ou notre foi.
Il existe peut-être, un grand plan divin qui autorise d'horribles souffrances
pour qu'à la fin tout rentre dans l'ordre.
Peut-être, mais ces idées sont justes des variations de Dieu contrôlant tout.
Le commandant suprême jouant avec des troupes extensibles dans une grande campagne
Nous voici avec un Dieu qui peut provoquer le tsunami et laisser faire Auschwitz.
Dostoïevsky, dans son grand roman, "Les frères Karamazov", fait dire à Ivan,
qui s'adresse a son jeune frère, naïf et dévoué, Alyosha:
"Et si la souffrance des enfants sert à parfaire la somme des douleurs
nécessaires à l’acquisition de la vérité,
j'affirme d’ores et déjà que cette vérité ne vaut pas un tel prix.
l’entrée coûte trop cher pour nous.
Ce n'est pas DIeu que je refuse.
mais très respectueusement, je lui rends mon billet."
Ou peut-être Dieu à mis en place l'univers et l'a positionné à son point de départ
et à ensuite renoncé à le contrôler pour toujours,
de sorte que les processus naturels peuvent se produire, et l'évolution suivre son cours.
Cela semble plus acceptable,
mais cela laisse à Dieu la responsabilité morale suprême.
Dieu est-il un spectateur froid et insensible?
Ou bien un amateur impuissant, observant avec une compassion infinie
les choses que Dieu est incapable de contrôler ou de changer ?
Dieu est-il intimement lié à notre souffrance,
au point qu'Il le ressente au plus profond de Son être?
Si nous croyons un chose pareille, nous devons abandonner complètement le grand marionnettiste,
oublier le contrôleur tout-puissant, abandonner les modèles traditionnels.
Nous devons repenser Dieu.
Dieu ne fait peut-être rien.
Dieu n'est peut-être pas un agent comme nous tous sommes des agents.
Les premières pensées religieuses voyaient Dieu comme une sorte de personne super humaine
faisant tout partout.
Battant les égyptiens, les noyant dans la mer rouge, dévastant les villes, se mettant en colère
Le peuple connaissait Dieu de part Ses actions.
Mais et si Dieu n'agit pas? Et si Dieu ne fait pas les choses du tout?
Et si Dieu est dans les choses?
L'âme aimante de l'univers?
Une présence compatissante permanente, soutenant et supportant toutes choses
Et si Dieu est dans les choses?
Dans le réseau infiniment complexe de relations et les connexions qui composent la vie.
Dans le cycle naturel de la vie et de la mort,
la création et la destruction qui doivent arriver continuellement.
Dans le processus de l’évolution.
dans l'incroyable complexité et splendeur de la nature
Dans l'inconscient collectif, l’âme de la race humaine.
En vous, en moi; cerveau, corps et esprit.
Dans le tsunami, dans les victimes. Dans la profondeur des choses.
Dans la présence et dans l'absence. Dans la simplicité et la complexité.
Dans le changement, le développement et la croissance
Comment fonctionne cette présence intérieure, cette intériorité
C'est dur à concevoir, et pose plus de questions.
Dieu est-il juste un autre nom pour l'univers,
sans existence en tant que tel?
Je ne sais pas.
Dans quelle mesure peut-on attribuer une personnalité à Dieu?
A la fin, nous nous devons dire, "Je ne sais pas."
Si nous savions, Dieu ne serait pas Dieu.
Avoir foi en Dieu
ressemblerait plus à avoir confiance en une bienveillance essentielle dans l'univers,
que plutot de croire dans un systeme de déclarations doctrinales.
N'est-il pas ironique que les chrétiens qui prétendent que croire
en un être infini, inconnaissable,
restreignent Dieu dans un système fermé et des doctrines rigides?
Comment peut-on pratiquer une telle foi?
En cherchant le Dieu intérieur. En cultivant ma propre intériorité.
Dans le silence, la méditation, dans mon for intérieur, dans le moi résiduel
quand je mets de coté mes émotions passagères, mes idées et mes préoccupations.
En prenant conscience de la conversation intérieure.
Et comment vivrions-nous une telle foi ? Comment vivrai-je une telle foi?
En cherchant une connexion intime avec votre for intérieur.
Un genre de relation quand le profond parle au profond.
Si Dieu est dans tout le monde, alors il y a un lieu de rencontre
quand ma relation avec vous devient une rencontre à trois.
Il y a un salut indien, je suis sur que certains d'entre vous connaissent:
"Namaste" accompagné d'une révérence respectueuse,
qui traduit à peu près veut dire
"Le divin en moi accueille le divin en vous"
Namaste.
Comment chacun appréhendrait une telle foi?
En cherchant le for intérieur qui est dans toutes choses.
Dans la musique et la poésie, dans le monde naturel de la beauté
dans les petites choses ordinaires de la vie,
il y a une profonde, présence intérieure qui rends ces choses extraordinaires.
Cela demande une profonde attention et une attente patiente.
Une attitude contemplative, de la générosité et de la franchise
a ceux dont l’expérience est différente de la mienne.
Quand je me tenais devant ma congrégation pour parler de Dieu et du tsunami
Je n'avais pas de réponses à leur offrir.
Pas de colis soigné de foi, avec des références bibliques pour les prouver.
Seulement des doutes, des interrogations et de l'incertitude.
J'avais quelques suggestions à faire --
des nouvelles voies possibles de penser Dieu.
Voies qui nous permettraient d'emprunter une route nouvelle et inexplorée.
Mais à la fin, la seule chose que je pouvais dire était, "Je ne sais pas"
et qui pourrait bien être la déclaration la plus profondément religieuse de toutes.
Merci.